ed sheeran dishes on his game of Thrones
cameo and being honored by the
Songwriters Hall of Fame I'm obviously
very very very honored ed Sheeran is
heading to Westeros the 26-year old
singer will appear in the series
upcoming seventh season and in typical
humble IDI fashion he told the teen what
we can expect the scene I did I did with
Maisie and it's a decent I like it I
like nothing exciting happens in the
scene we just have a conversation that's
kind of it anything over the ruber reel
anything gravy happen I didn't put on my
thermal socks and I was outside in the
winter in England for about ten hours so
it was cold I feel like my cameo has
been built up too much some people will
just be like oh alright like it's not an
integral part of it at all I'm just like
in it and then it doesn't matter whose
skeleton sits on the Iron Throne ET
spoke with it at the Songwriters Hall of
Fame's 48th annual induction in Awards
Gala on Thursday where he was honoured
with the Hal David starlight award I
think it's a bit premature I'm obviously
very very very honored to be here and
thrilled to be in a room with people
that inspired me to write some
[Music]